started out as a house fire turned into  a shocking discovery of an illegal  marijuana growing operation in the west  valley  neighbors say they had no idea what was  going on right in their own backyard  well that was until police showed up and  discovered 800 marijuana plants inside  the home was also rigged complete with  electrical work lighting and fertilizer  when you hear something like a fire  happening in a house that's growing  pots you just go crazy like this isn't  supposed to happen in my neighborhood  luckily the fire didn't spread to any  surrounding homes it was contained  fairly quickly on sunday morning no  injuries reported right now narcotics  detectives are following up on leads so  if you know anything you are encouraged  to call crime stoppers